if I can ask a pothead question for a
second so you mentioned just like the
silkworms the individualists silkworms
got uh to actually learn how to
collaborate or actually to collaborate
like in a swarm like way you're talking
about getting plants to communicate in
some interesting way based on an
objective function is it possible
to have some kind of interface between
another kind of organisms humans and
nature so like a human to have a
conversation with with a plant there
already is you know that when we cut
freshly cut grass I love the smell but
it's a smell of actually it's a smell of
distress that the Leaves of Grass are
communicating to each other so the grass
when it's cut emits green leaf volatiles
glvs and those glvs are basically one
leaf of grass communicating to another
Leaf of grass be careful mind you you're
about to be cut
these incredible life forms are
communicating using a different language
than ours we use language models they
use molecular models at the moment where
we can pass in we can we can decode
these molecular moments is when we can
start having a conversation with plants
now of course there is a lot of work
around Plant neurobiology it's a real
thing plants do not have a nervous
system
but they have something akin to a
nervous system it has a kind of a
ecological intelligence that is focused
on a particular time scale and the time
scale is very very slow slow slow time
scale so it is when we can melt these
time scales and and and and connect with
these plants in terms of the content of
the language in this case molecules the
duration of the language and we can
start having a conversation if not
simply to understand what is happening
in the plant kingdom Precision
agriculture I promise to you will look
very very different right because right
now we're using drones to take photos of
crops of corn that look bad and when we
take that photo it's already too late
but if we understand these molecular
Footprints and things that they are
trying to say the stress that they are
trying to communicate then we could of
course predict the physiological
biological behavior of these crops both
for for their own a self-perpetuation
but also for the the foods and and the
Pharma and and the type of molecules
that we're seeking to grow for the
benefit of humanity and so these
languages
um that we are attempting now to
quantify and qualify uh will really help
us not only better nature and help
nature in its uh striving to surviving
but also help us uh you know design
better wines and uh you know and and
better foods and and and better medicine
and better products again across all
scales across all application domains is
there intricacies to understanding the
time scales like you mentioned at which
these communications these languages
like operate is there something
different
between the way humans communicate and
the way plants communicate in terms of
time remember when we started the
conversation talking about
sort of definitions in the context of
design and then in the context of being
that question requires I think a kind of
a shift
um
a humility that requires a kind of a
humility towards nature understanding
that it operates on different scales we
recently discovered that uh you know
that the molecular footprint of a rose
or of a plant in general during night
time is different than its molecular
footprint during daytime so these are
circadian rhythms that are associated
with
um what kind of molecules these plants
emit
um given stress stresses and given
um you know there's a reason why uh why
the Jasmine Jasmine field smells so so
delicious and 4 am in the morning and
then there's like there's there's peace
and rest amongst you know amongst the
plants and you have to sort of tune into
that
time dimension of of the plant kingdom
and that of course requires all this
humility where in a single capsule to
design a biodiversity chamber it will
take years not months and definitely not
days and to see these products and also
that humility in design comes from
Simply you know looking at how we are
today as a civilization how we use an
abused nature like just think of all
these Christmas trees right these
Christmas trees they take years to grow
we use them for one night the holiest
night of the year
and then we let them go and think about
in nature to design a quote-unquote
product an organism spends energy and
time and thoughtfulness and many many
years and I'm thinking about the
Redwoods
um to grow these channels these you know
the cellulose layers and channels and
reach these incredible Heights takes
sometimes hundreds of years sometimes
thousands of years am I afraid of
building a company that designs products
in the scale of thousands of years no
I'm not and the way of being in the
physical world today is really not in
tune with the time dimension of the
natural world at all and um and and that
needs to change and that's obviously
very very hard to do in a community in
of of of human beings that is at least
in the western world that is based on
capitalism and so here the wonderful
challenge that we have ahead of us is
how do we impart upon the capitalist
Movement we know that we need to produce
Now Products that will enter the real
world and be you know shared and used by
others and still benefit the natural
world while benefiting humans and that's
a wonderful challenge to have so
integrate technology with nature and
that's a really difficult problem I see
parallels here with another company of
neuralink which is
is basically like you I think you
mentioned your link for nature that
their short-term products you can come
up with but it's ultimately a long-term
challenge of how do you integrate the
machine
with this creation of nature this
intricate complex creation of nature
which is the human brain and then you're
speaking more generally nature
you know how every company has an image
like this one single image that embodies
the spirit of the company and I think
for neurolink it was to me that
chimpanzee playing a video game
it was just unbelievable but with plants
there potentially is a set of molecules
that
impacts or inspires I like that word the
plant to
um behave or act in a certain way and
allows still to plan the possibility of
deciding where it or she or he wants to
go
which is why our first product for this
molecular space is going to be a
functionalized fragrance
so here we're thinking about the future
of fragrances and the future fragrances
and flavors
um you know these these products are in
the industry as we know it today are
designed for totally for a human-centric
use and
um and enjoyment and Indulgence and
luxury
um they're used on the body for the sake
of I don't know attraction and and
feeling good
um and smelling good and we were asking
ourselves is there a world in which
um in which a fragrance can be not a
functional fragrance because you could
claim that all fragrances are functional
but is there a world in which the
fragrance becomes functionalized is
again imparted upon or given agency to
connect with another organism is there a
world in which
um you and I can go down to your garden
and use a perfume that will interact
with the Rose Garden downstairs
um I've just been enamored with the
statements that are being made
in the media around oh this is
completely biologically derived
fragrance and it's bio-based and but
when you look into the fragrance and you
understand it in order to get to this
bioderived fragrant fragrance you went
through you blew through you know 10 000
10 000 bushes of rose to create five
milliliters of of a rose fragrance and
all these ten thousand bushes of Rose
they take space they take you know water
management and and so much waste um is
this really what we want the future of
our Agriculture and molecular Goods to
look like and so when we did the ago
Pavilion on the roof of SF Moma we
calculated that for that Pavilion we had
40 000 calories embedded into this
Pavilion that was made of shrimp shells
and kaitizen and apple skins and and
cellulose from tree tree pulp and we
calculated that overall the structure
had 40 000 calories interesting way to
think about a structure right from this
from the point of view of of calories
but as you left the gallery you saw
these three clocks that were so
beautifully designed by Felix on our
team and these clocks measured
temperature and humidity and we were
connected them to Weather Channels so
that we could directly
um look at how the Pavilion was
biodegrading in real time and and and in
our calculations I say this long-winded
uh description of the Pavilion to say
that in the calculation we incorporated
um you know how much electricity we used
for our computers for the 3D printers
that printed the Pavilion and you know
and these were called emergy
calculations right energy and materials
and when you think about a product and
you think about you know a shoe or a
chair or a perfume or a building you
don't stop at the object you want to go
all the way to the system again instead
of Designing objects or singular
embodiments of a the will of the
designer you're really tapping into an
entire system that is interconnected and
if you look at the energy budget that
characterized the project
it traverses the entire planet right
some of these shrimp shells were brought
from places in the world we haven't
thought of in terms of the apples and
the shrimp shells and the tree pop and
so going back to you know going back to
to fragrances
um it's really really important to
understand the product in the context of
the ecological system from which it's
sourced and and how it's designed and
that is the kind of thinking
um that is not only desired but is
required if we are to achieve Synergy
between humanity and nature it's
interesting because the system level
thinking is almost always going to take
you to the entire Earth to considering
the entire Earth ecosystem which is why
it's important to have a left brain and
a right brain competing for attention
you mentioned a fragrance that kind of
sends out a message to the environment
essentially a message in a bottle yeah a
message in a bottle so like so you can
go to a rose garden and trick the Rose
Garden to think it's 4 AM
essentially you could if you wanted to
but maybe that is not trick trick is a
bad word right Inspire but Inspire I
like I I like the idea of providing
nature with a choice which is why I love
that elegant mathematical equation of
empowerment and agency empower the uh
the Rose Garden to uh to create a
romantic moment for the uh for the
wearer of the fragrance but now again
you're you're again all of this to go
back to back to that human-centric
notion of romance but maybe there's
another way to do romance right that
that we haven't yet you know that we
haven't yet explored and and maybe
you know there's a way to tap into what
happens to the Rose when it's dreaming
assuming that plants are sentient and
assuming that we can tap into that
sentience what can we discover about
what what does the Rose want like what
is what is it actually want and and and
what does it need and what are what what
are the Roses
um you know
dreams but do you think there's some
correlation in terms of romance in terms
of the word you sometimes use Magic
is there some similarities in what
humans want and what roses want and what
nature wants I think so
I think there isn't if I did not think
so oh my goodness this would not be a
nice world to live in I think
we all want love
I recently read this beautiful letter
that was written by Einstein to his
daughter
um and was discovered Einstein asked his
daughter to wait 20 years until she
reveals these letters and so she did
it's just one of the most beautiful
letters I've ever read from a father to
his daughter and the letter overall is
imbued with a kind of a a sense of
remorse or
maybe even feelings of sadness and there
is some kind of melancholy note in the
letter uh where Einstein regrets not
having spent enough time with his
daughter having focused on you know the
fear of general relativity and changing
the world and then he goes on to talk
about this beautiful and elegant
equation of E equals MC square and he
tells his daughter that he believes that
love is actually the force that shapes
the universe because it is like gravity
right it attracts people it is like
light it brings people together and
connects between people and it's all
empowering and and so if you multiply it
by the the speed of light you could
really change the world for the better
and I I call me a romanticist I know you
are too
um which is why I so love being here I I
believe in this I I totally and utterly
um believe in in love but let me just
excerpt from Einstein's letter there's
an extremely powerful force that's so
far science has not found a formal
explanation to it is a force that
includes and governs all others and is
even behind any phenomena operating in
the universe and has not yet been
identified by us this Universal force is
love
he also the last paragraph in the letter
as you've mentioned I deeply regret not
having been able to express what is in
my heart which has quietly beaten for
you all my life maybe it's too late to
apologize but as time is relative
that jokes to Einstein I need to tell
you that I love you and uh thanks to you
I've reached the ultimate answer your
father Albert Einstein yeah for that
regret I deeply regret not having been
able to express what is in my heart
maybe that's a universal regret
filling your days with busyness
and silly Pursuits and not
sitting down and uh expressing that but
it is
everything it is everything it is why I
love that expression and I forget who
said this but
I I love my daughter more than
um Evolution required right and
um I feel the same way towards
my other half and and I feel that when
you find that connection
um everything and anything is possible
um and it's a very very very magical
[Music]
um
a magical moment so I
I believe in love and I believe in the
one